Ich hatte einen Traum, es ist, als hätte er mich angerufen, aber
als ich meine Augen öffnete, sah ich einen
kleinen Jungen in meiner Schlafzimmertür stehen, es
war dreimal und nach diesem Traum,
was ich habe, und ich sehe es, weil ich das
sehe und danach in
dieser Nacht  An diesem Morgen klingelt das Telefon natürlich 12 Minuten bei
United
will nicht alles sagen was
ich meine ist er sagte er kann nicht darüber
reden du weißt und erzähl mir alles
weil ich will in unserem rennen es macht mir sorgen
du weißt alles du weißt deine mutter
es macht mir sorgen warum warum du  sind so
jung, sagte ich Mami, wenn ich
jetzt nach Südafrika zurückkomme, wenn du
jetzt meins bekommst, und ich verachte alles
, was du siehst, das Ding ist, was du denkst, und das
Geld, was du für
dich zurücklegst, wenn du ein schönes Haus für ihn bekommst  und welches
Geld ist auf der Bank, zumindest nicht sie
w  Als er zu Besuch kam, kaufte er uns wie
eine Glocke, es ist ein Ball, den ich
normalerweise den Kühen anlege, und wir bekamen jeder wie ein kleiner
Darm und mit der Flagge darauf, wie
er früher geblieben ist, und das war so besonders
für mich, weil ich  bedeutet, dass das
wirklich etwas Großes für mich war und er
uns immer brachte, du weißt schon, er wird in
die Flasche tun, du wirst ein bisschen Schnee
tun, und wenn wir es brauchen, ist es wie
Wasser, aber er wird mir sagen, dass du weißt, dass es das
ist  etwas Schnee, es ist jetzt Wasser, aber du kannst es
werfen, du weißt, behalte es für dich.
Ich habe mich noch nicht von meinem
Bruder
verabschiedet
Manchmal am Tag fühlt es sich einfach so an, als hätte ich keine
Chance, ihm zu sagen, dass du
niemals über deinen Sohn hinwegkommen wirst, wenn du
deinen Sohn nie verloren hast, denn wenn es schwarz
in deinem Herzen bleibt, ist es dein Kind